pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche tient bon
salut les épis curieux c'est un
reblochon
drôle de nom pour un fromage jeu ce
n'est pas celui d'un lieu dit ni celui
d'un personnage
il n'est pas non plus liée à sa forme
alors 12 sorties
ce mot vient du patois savoyard blocher
qui signifie traire le préfixe hébreu
indique la répétition de l'action
la décomposition de ce mot coïncide avec
une histoire qui se transmet depuis des
générations en savoir dès le xiiie
siècle les propriétaires des alpages
en général les nobles ou des moines
percevait un impôt auprès des fermiers
qui faisait paître leurs troupeaux de
vaches ils étaient réglés en nature
amber en lait ou en fromage l'impôt
était calculée sur la quantité de lait
produite chaque jour par le troupeau
cette quantité de lait était vérifié une
fois par an par un contrôleur ce jour là
et les paysans réaliser une traite
incomplète
la quantité de lait pesé sans trouver
donc diminué par rapport à la normale et
l'impôt aussi aussitôt le contrôleur
partie les fermiers retourne à finir la
traite
il allait re blanche et le lait de cette
deuxième traite même s'il n'était pas
très abondants et est plus gras est donc
idéal pour faire un fromage
un reblochon et moi je vais re goûter au
re voir
ces robots si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
on